look how poor out
alfie and helen taylor had lived here
for nearly 40 years
now in their 70s they must start again
from scratch
even to them the home they devoted
decades to is unrecognizable
a site that's simply too much this last
couple of days it started sinking in but
we've lost everything because our home
we've lost all our belongings
this is the longest time i've been here
seeing it
it's just devastating
there was a marble fireplace there
because everybody tried to fight off us
and said no it's partly ass
alfie was here when the flames
approached but was forced to flee
empty-handed
my baby the classic car he spent years
restoring now crushed and partially
melted
there is a cruel irony to what has
survived the fire my mother
died
in taiwan
just before i died just before my mum
died
and i thought it's all gone
anymore
most importantly they say they still
have each other
as our summers get hotter the question
many are asking is how do you stop this
from happening again the council here
has already told me they're looking at
changing policy when it comes to land
like this around villages to keep grass
cut short rather than letting it grow
long or installing fire breaks in fields
but this is an issue faced not just here
it's nationwide i'll be honest i feel
quite detached from it really it's very
odd
despite the threat of future fires shane
turner says he will move back here as
soon as his house is rebuilt but he
wants to see fire services boosted his
home one of at least 17 destroyed is
just meters from the local fire station
whose crews were deployed elsewhere when
the flames took hold government needs to
support our fire brigade i think that
when they need more funding we're
understaffed here anyway and
for them to say that we're going to cut
services further i don't think that's a
very good thing to do and if if we look
at this as being something to do with
climate change then it's something
that's going to be happening more
regularly and therefore we actually need
more firefighters not less
the clear-up operation here will take
months if not years but the damage
caused by the fire will eventually
disappear the threat from climate change
though is here to stay ivor bennett sky
news wentington in greater london